[موسيقى]
تجارب السياحيه الممتعه تمنحها المجالس
التراثيه في مدينه الجبيل الصناعيه لزوار
والوفود السياحيه التي تحاكي بطبيعتها
الموروث القديمه للبيئه الخليجيه عبد
الرحيم الشريف احد المهتمين بالتراث تعلقه
بالماضي دفعه الى انشائي مجلس الشريف
التراثي الذي يحتضر العديد من اللقاءات
الثقافيه ويستقطب الزوار بين الجبيل
وخارجها حبي في التراث هو اللي خلاني
اعملي هذا المجلس طبعا هذا كنت انا احلم
فيه من زمان اني اعمل المجلس التراثي
القديم وطلعت بالشكل هذا والحمد لله كثير
من الزوار يجي يزور المجلس ويطلع بصوره
حلوه
في الماضي والحس في الانتماء اذا دخلنا
المجلس هذا
ويكون في حديث
عن الماضي القديم عن كل قطعه فيها المجلس
تتكلم عن عن الماضي الجبيل القديم
ومنها للتعارف اكثر الناس سواء من السواح
او من المدينه يجون المجلس هذا ويصير فيه
تعارف يصير فيه
تبادل ثقافات وافكار مع بعض
يحتفظوا احمد البويت بنحويه
3500 من الدلال بمختلف الاحجام والمسميات
يعود تاريخ بعضها الى مئه عام اضافه الى
العديد من القطاع والمقتنيات الاثريه التي
يتزين بها مجلس البويه التراثي احد
المقاصد السياحيه للزوار في مدينه الجبيل
الصناعيه اغلب المقتنعات التي اخذت السنين
يعني من عمرنا على تجميعها على كذا
والاغلب منهم موث من الجدود طبعا دلال
عمارها يعني تبتدي من 50 سنه الى 200 سنه
اكثر من 350 دله من اصل 3,500 يمتلكها
الوالد
وعندنا انواع الخناجر باختلاف احجامها
وانواعها وايضا عندنا من انواع المباخر
وايضا نمتلك من بعض السيوف
طبعا كلها قديمه
تضيفوا المجالس التراثيه في مدينه الجبيل
الصناعيه مسارا سياحيا واحدا يحتاج الى
المزيد من الدعم والتمكين الا وهو مسار
سياحته التراثيه من الجبيل الصناعيه عالي
اللغبي العربيه